[Music]
I don't want a lot for
Christmas there are just two things I
need I don't care about those
Rebels underneath the Endor
trees I just want you for my
own more than Palpatine's all thrown
droids so gold and
blue All I Want For Christmas Is
[Music]
You
I don't want a lot for
Christmas I just need to find those
droids I'm just going to keep on
searching through the jaw is and
humanoids I've been searching high and
low now flying all through outter
space cuz you two left without me yeah
you left without a
trace I just want you here tonight
staring in those blinking
lights droids what can I
do all I want for Christmas is
you I won't ask for much this
Christmas not even for Huff's cold
snow I'm just going to keep on
searching 42 nc3
poo there's no sense in hanging stock
high up in the Tie Fighter
Bay Vader he won't make me happy with a
promotion on Christmas day I just want
you here
tonight staring in those blinking
lights droids what can I
do all I want for Christmas is
you the death stars light is shining so
bright on
alderon and the sound of millions voices
now are
gone and everyone is
looking I can smell those Farmers
cooking Luke won't you bring me the ones
I really want won't you please bring
those droids to
me I don't want a lot for
Christmas this is all I'm asking for no
I just want to see those two
droids standing right outside my
door I just want you for my
own more than Palpatine all
thrown droids so gold and
blue All I Want For Christmas Is
[Applause]
You Is
[Music]
[Applause]
You
la